it's been very toxic and intense and
Beth Douglas has known since her late
teens she was transgender she'd hoped
Scotland's gender recognition act would
have made life easier for people like
her that was until the UK government
intervened it felt like a gut punch I
would be completely telling a lie if if
I didn't feel heartbroken a bit about
this this is a huge attack on trans
people living in Scotland and around the
UK but it's even bigger than just us
it's about Scottish democracy itself
the man who halted the legislation is
Rishi sunax Scottish secretary Mr
Speaker I have not taken this decision
lightly it is our assessment that the
bill would have a serious adverse impact
among other things on the operation of
the equality act 2010. those adverse
effects include impacts on the operation
of single-sex clubs associations and
schools and protections such as equal
pay
the fact one Parliament has overall
legislation approved by another has led
Nicholas sturgeon to confirm she will
take this to court while her ministers
worry about the impact on Devolution I
question what the implications are for
future legislation of this Parliament
the secretary of state says that he
wants to find a constructive way forward
but the UK government had multiple
opportunities to provide constructive
comments during the extensive
consultation on the bill and during its
passage and it did not do so
culture wars meet constitutional ones
and all because of one bill
the ACT removes the need for a medical
diagnosis of gender dysphoria reduces
the age from 18 to 16 at which you can
start applying for a gender recognition
certificate but critics argue it could
have widespread consequences including
four Single Sex spaces like women's
shelters and prisons
others argue the impact is far wider the
unintended consequence of this will be a
massive boost in support for the s p
they will see their support from go on
and in the long run you can't really not
address this issue this controversy has
now also highlighted divisions on the
issue within the UK conservative and
labor parties as for relations between
Scotland's two governments they had been
thawing but now seem to be back in the
Deep Freeze Joe Pike Sky News Edinburgh